ah
[Music]
despite what it looks like i didn't pray
to god that night
i prayed to blaze pascal my thinking was
if he was right about the existence of
god then he could pass along my request
for my dad to get better
if he was wrong well
in this moment i needed him to be right
[Music]
what's taking so long keep your voice
down
car thief i didn't steal your car i just
borrowed it
you're gonna need to make bail someday
do not
come to me good news your daddy's gonna
be fine
should be home in a day or two oh and
was it a heart attack
minor no permanent damage oh that's
wonderful
our prayers have been answered
come on everybody let's say hello to
your old dad
for a brief moment i was filled with the
healing power of
faith then the next day we all got
violently ill from billy sparks eggs and
i was over it
i thought i'd talk this morning about
how it all began
now everybody knows on the first day of
creation
god said let there be light and there
was light
and when god saw that light he knew it
was good
oh here we go yes sheldon
you said he didn't create the sun until
day four
yeah so how could there be light the
first three days
god is light so god's a photon
god's what made photons possible and
what day did he do that
i would think day one how could i grab
my chest and kill over maybe we can get
out of here
that's a terrible thing because the
first day had just begun
so before the big bang there was no big
bang
there was only the word was the word
kaboom
okay do it we gotta go
[Music]
foreign
you